[Music]
emily is in st louis hi emily how are
you
i'm great how are you better than we
deserve how can we help
well first i wanted to say you don't get
enough credit for your amazing comedic
timing so if you get sick of this whole
radio thing you could always do stand up
instead oh bless your heart i'm here for
that netflix special
[Laughter]
how can we help
so i'm about to jump up in rent from
900 to almost double that at 1600 a
month
and i just wanted to make sure i'm not
making a big mistake because
i do have a relatively low income
i net about
2500
a month
but so the reason why i
do think that
it might be okay for me to do that is i
am very fortunate to have a trust fund
and i do draw
700 a month from that and then it is
always just there in the background
i i try not to even think about that it
exists because i want to save that for
my retirement
but it is there
what do you do for a living
um well luckily it's george today
instead of john's because i'm in doggy
daycare i heard you guys arguing about
that recently
okay you oh you do doggy daycare yeah
yeah i'm not here
i missed that discussion okay i can only
imagine
okay uh and but you're not making much
money
correct so what's your long-term career
plan
well um phil i'm 34 and for a long time
i really didn't have a career plan
um because i had a very difficult
multi-year
struggle with crippling anxiety and
depression
um and it gets started turning around
when i actually
started working in doggy daycare it
changed my entire life
and now i'm like when i used to be
miserable it was very hard for me to get
out of bed in the morning
and now i'm just like one of the
happiest people i know
um i have the pandemic um
actually
i'm i'm an introvert and
it's kind of i feel bad saying that the
pandemic
really was great for my mental health
because i
like had this three month period where i
just got as much
alone time as i needed without
neglecting my friends or family or my
job
and but it really just started me on
this big upward trajectory of healing
and um
so now i am
i do feel like maybe i could without
jeopardizing my mental health start
looking in other directions
um
unfortunately the other direction i want
to look in is the screenwriting that my
degree is in film
obviously that
i think you can start that now
i think you can start that now while
you're doing this and i think you need
to start i actually have
making some extra money right now
because honey you know i really love the
doggy daycare has helped with your
anxiety i love all that i think that's
fun
and i like that part of your story uh
what i don't like is that you're you're
trading it for another kind of anxiety
called financial anxiety because you
don't make any money
and um you cannot do rent that is 50 of
your income
and and prosper right you're not going
to prosper
so no the sixteen hundred dollar rent
with a thirty two hundred dollar income
including your trust money
uh that's fifty percent of your income
you're gonna
struggle and um and i you know so
i i would stay with the 900 for a while
um and
so i've been at the
900 for four years actually and it's a
teeny tiny apartment
um about 275 square feet doesn't matter
you can't afford it
doesn't matter
you can't afford to go to 50
it's just you know it's like okay uh you
know i'm driving an old car
but i and i'd really like a brand new uh
car well you can't afford it you don't
have any money
you know and so that's kind of where
this is and it's cold but it's a math
thing it's not a an emotion thing now
what i do want you to do is i do want
you to have some hope to move into a
better place but that hope is tied to
changing your income that's why i was
asking you those other questions yeah
the thing emily i want you to think
about is your long-term future not just
what's going to happen next year but the
next 10 years where do i want to be do i
want to be a homeowner because rent's
going to keep going up
and so when you think about it that way
50 of your take-home pay being eaten up
by your rent means you're not going to
be able to save up for that down payment
you're not going to be able to invest 15
and retire with dignity so i want you to
think longer term and make decisions
based on that so the good news is is
there are plenty of ways for folks that
are introverts to make a lot of money it
does not require that you put yourself
in a highly
uh in a crowded room
you know every day all day to make a
living i i wouldn't recommend that i'm
not proposing that to you but i do want
you to say okay what can i do that gives
me the same kind of peace
that what i'm currently doing
does
and makes three times more
and i don't know what that is exactly
it could be it could be in the writing
area it could be
the good news is that you can do a lot
of writing now from home and uh and then
you move up into a little better place
and then you start saving for a house
but we got to get your income up long
term or you're going to be trading one
kind of anxiety for another that's
what's going to end up happening and no
i cannot i'm going to beg you not to do
the 1600 in rent until you do something
to change your income hold on uh we're
going to have the team pick up and send
you a copy of ken coleman's book from
paycheck to purpose and also the career
assessment as well the career assessment
uh and that'll help you maybe determine
some ideas of some things you could work
on that that would be
beneficial
the good news in our current world
george is that there's so many jobs
available
there's such a shortage of labor in
almost every area
that she can probably find something
that is not a high stress
you know high anxiety situation every
headline is there's a shortage of pizza
delivery drivers now yeah and so you can
go make really good money 25 bucks an
hour delivering pizzas she can actually
make more than she's making now doing
that um and this it doesn't have to be
forever people think well i don't want
to do that well i'm asking you to do it
for a year to clean your financial mess
up yeah and there's a i mean we saw an
article come out yesterday every pizza
hut dominoes
um
they're all uh they're seeing drop in
sales
and and their revenues are down not
because people don't want pizzas but
because they don't have any drivers to
deliver them and when delivery is down
sales are down and so all of them stock
is hurting
and they're because their profits are
down because they're not delivering
pizzas they can't get drivers and so
there is a shortage and so this is you
know what biden bucks did when you pay
people not to work people here's how
this works when you pay people not to
work guess what they do they don't work
they don't work
how's that what's that called cause and
effect
that's scientific yeah
see economics
economics it's a it's a tricky little
business this econ thing
uh
yeah pay people not to work and then
they won't work
create a shortage of anything and the
price goes up
supply and demand people
so guess what your inflation is caused
by
labor cost gone through the roof you
can't get people to work
this is the ramsey chef